in december 1988 the leaders of china
and india
met for the first time in nearly three
decades
the summit which came after years of
tense border disputes
marked a turning point towards
friendlier relations it was a time
of hope a china in transition
the range of possibilities then was wide
and as the millennium came to a close
all eyes were on the future
of the continent amidst this optimism
china's leader deng xiaoping was
skeptical
despite what people have predicted he
cautioned
there was no guarantee of an asian
century
never mind that he coined this term with
hesitation
the concept of an asian century would
soon take on a life of its own
thanks to a pattern of successes there
was
its relatively stronger performance
during the 2008 financial crisis
the rapid growth of its four tigers hong
kong
singapore south korea and taiwan
and of course its explosive population
and middle class the basic premise
was that as asia's supply chains
integrated its navies modernized and
trade dominated
this momentum would shift the global
center of gravity to the east
this notion increasingly rephrased as
the rise of
china escaped the fringes entered the
public consciousness
and was thoroughly beat into all of our
heads
though likely to evoke different
emotions its truthfulness
was no longer controversial and then no
longer even
interesting a cliche it's
not hard to see why it contextualizes
and attaches an enviable momentousness
to the present moment in time
in just two words it neatly encapsulates
three centuries of history into that of
europe
america and now asia
it seems to confirm what we already know
in a way that suggests a larger trend
a narrative at the same time the
nebulousness of what it implies
in concrete terms helped it evade
scrutiny
and take on several independent meanings
after years now decades of snowballing
predictions
optimistic models best-selling books and
emotive profiles designed to stoke fear
after 10 000 repetitions of the next
superpower
great power rivalry china's grand
strategy
and the remaking of the world order this
once very simple idea has lost all sight
of reality
like an overvalued startup unchecked
hyperbole has driven its mental market
share
way out of proportion beneath the
mountains of wishful thinking and
grandiose predictions
there is merit make no mistake but it's
time
for a return to the fundamentals
a reckoning is long overdue
this is part one we begin with the
challenge to china's supremacy
which underpins all others one so
insidious that it can only be solved by
its very nature
over the course of decades china
will soon run out of people
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the extended version
of this video
the absolute size of a population says a
lot about it
in the broadest of strokes a big country
buys more things giving it greater
leverage
a tiny country on the other hand will
more likely rely on its neighbors
none of this is revolutionary which is
to say
there's a good reason that when we talk
about the size of a country in relation
to its global significance
we're usually referring not to its
square footage
but number of unique humans the problem
is that this number can also be just as
misleading as it is useful
when we compare population sizes we
mentally take for granted a
typical nation we imagine in other words
a similar proportion of doctors students
seniors babies and plumbers
a reasonable shorthand for 90 of
conversations
this however is one of the remaining ten
big uniquely consequential countries get
that way by adopting
big uniquely consequential policies
which means
this single number just won't cut it
ideally we could visualize each
individual person
along with their education occupation
and household size
things which on average are known to
affect their nation as a whole
but in the absence of some revolution in
infographics
demographers have settled on the next
best thing
realizing that just one number is
remarkably accurate at predicting your
contribution to the country
age to show this a population pyramid
splits a country into age cohorts
the longer the rectangle the larger that
share of the population
the magic thing about age is that while
sure the precise boundaries of things
like retirement and adulthood
may differ slightly between countries
cohort behavior
is tied to a set of universal biological
facts which
transcend culture now let's add some
detail to be more scientific
and see what those look like i promise
this is going somewhere
the first group are seniors with only
their savings remaining
retirees are low spenders have little
room for risk
and thanks to their prudence are of the
least interest to most marketers
the second group are the producers and
economically the only one that matters
during our 30s and 40s we reached the
peak of our earning potential
and put all that money into stocks
retirement funds and expensive vacations
another name for this group might be the
greats
nearly all of the world's nobel prize
winners and great inventors
were in this age bracket the average age
of top startup founders
is 45. these individuals have an
outsized influence on the world
and thus even a small change in their
size ripples throughout the nation
next are the borrowers students fresh
graduates and the drivers of demand for
loans
finally and most useless of them all are
babies
little money eating machines which
conveniently wait several decades before
offering
anything of value alright now that we've
defined each cohort we can begin to see
why their relative size is where the
magic happens
while there may not be a single most
optimal shape
there are certainly more and less
desirable shapes economically speaking
and each kind of imbalance will lead to
a different kind of problem
or benefit to show this let's imagine
the unrealistic extremes
if 90 of a country were babies we'd have
a national babysitter shortage
lots of crying and not much else
if 90 were aged between 30 and 60
it'd be amazingly productive punching
well
above its weight class with no
dependence to care for
but fast forward 20 years and it would
all come crashing down
as they all retired at the same time and
waited for social security which there'd
be no one left to pay for
expect total social collapse
now none of this is to discount the role
of culture
political system physical environment or
any other factor for that matter
all of these things play a role but
think of them as a few
of the necessary ingredients the egg
sugar and butter to demography's
flour without the ingredient of
functional government you can't bake the
cookie
but no matter how effective the
government how strong the military
or influential the economy none of it is
sufficient
if you're missing the final key
ingredient the right population
another way of saying this is that by
looking only at the shape of a country's
population
without any absolute numbers or extra
information
we can already get a sense of its range
of possible futures
we can tell for example that this super
fast growing country has a massive
opportunity if it industrializes fast
enough
it could harness this large working age
cohort with few dependents
to modernize and raise the standard of
living
if those in power fail to manage that
transition
the larger population will only mean
more starvation
more disease and less land this is
nigeria
likewise we can conclude that this one
has just experienced
decades of miraculous growth but will
soon
and very quickly age shrinking
considerably
in the process how the government
responds will determine whether this is
merely disastrous
or truly catastrophic this
is china it's past 40 years of
celebrated growth
the basis for predictions of china's
rise the
source of general optimism the trend
which many assume will continue
coincides with this hump in the pyramid
which represents tens of millions of
extra people
in their prime working years everything
that made china what it is today
has relied on a large young and
productive workforce
now that workforce is about to succumb
to biology
just as every other generation has in
every other country
ever graphs describing china tend to
take this
shape but demographers know better they
know that this has only
been a temporary transitional state on
the road to industrialization
it even has a name it's called a
demographic
dividend during this time life
expectancy is still catching up
meaning there are few retirees at the
same time
fewer babies are being born as women
receive access to education
for these few years and only these few
years
the country in transition has all the
manpower
in the world which when well coordinated
translates to
exceptional economic growth
there's a painful flip side however
what looks like a dividend will
eventually feel more like a loan
the scary thing about retirement is that
it happens
all at once while income tends to rise
steadily throughout your career
it doesn't much fade away at 65.
one day you retire and that day your
income falls to zero
which is to say in a few years these
workers will retire
moving the pyramid upward and leaving
the country's future to this
shrinking base and it will happen all at
once
remember this little hump was behind the
last few decades of growth
and this little dip represents its
future
china's working age cohort grew from 58
of the country in 1978 to 74
in 2010 but in less than 20 years
the un predicts that number will be
roughly back where it was
in 78. by then china will have twice as
many seniors as
children under 15 and at the end of this
century
its total population will be cut in half
you might think that having worked
during this growth phase china's elders
will be well prepared for retirement
but its per capita wealth remains low
on the level of mexico the maldives and
kazakhstan
that means this massive retirees won't
just contribute less to the economy
but will also require immense financial
support
the kind china's fractured pension and
health care system
isn't remotely prepared for put simply
all of china's recent progress has been
bought on credit
and it's finally coming time to repay
now why you might ask can't chinese
people simply have
more babies if families were once larger
why can't they just return that way
recall however that because of the
20-year gap
between a baby born today and its first
real contribution to society
the damage is already done demography
plays out over the course of generations
and today's smaller baby cohort will
mean even
fewer babies when they reach adulthood
but fine setting aside that this problem
can only be solved in a
minimum of two decades even if the
solution were known and
implemented tomorrow remember what we're
talking about
it's easy to get lost in the language of
generations and cohorts
demography can unfortunately be
dehumanizing
and in the process lose sight of what
fertility
really means the very complex decision
of adults
to have children some of this choice
is beyond the reach of government
perception of parenthood
tradition and family are first and
foremost
formed based on one's own family
unfortunately for china the one-child
policy
has set the cultural expectation firmly
at
one and one just isn't enough
assuming it takes two people to make a
baby together they need
at least two just to replace themselves
plus
a small fraction more to account for
early deaths
that means a country needs a total
fertility rate
the number of children the average woman
will have in her lifetime
of 2.1 just to sustain its current
population
china's is currently 1.6 if you believe
the government
if you don't believe the average chinese
woman has 1.6 children
in a country where the vast majority
were until recently
only allowed to have one then you might
be tempted to believe someone like e
fujan a scientist at the university of
wisconsin-madison
who estimates the true number at 1.18
to get a better sense of just how hard
this problem is
think of fertility rate as an ungainly
machine
controlled by 100 different unlabeled
levers
policymakers know of at least a few
levers that will predictably lower the
tfr
but once the machine has slowed there's
neither a clear way of getting it going
again
nor any proof that it's even possible at
the scale necessary
there is on the other hand precedent for
these attempts
failing even by proud and authoritarian
singapore
but before we pour salt on this
demographic wound
let's be fair and start with the
positive
for starters chinese workers are
becoming better educated
meaning it will take fewer workers to
make the same economic contribution
and to the extent that automation
replaces labor the need for a strong
working age population may
diminish leaving china with the same old
challenges faced by other automated
countries
it would also be unfair not to mention
that china's problem
stems from a few strictly good
developments
women are choosing to have fewer babies
because they can
and seniors are living longer thanks to
a rise in standards of living
these richer longer and more fulfilling
lives have value on their own
now a summary of the bad news
there's a lack of reliable data and
reporting which means no one truly knows
how bad the problem is
the simultaneous rising life expectancy
means
seniors will burden the economy for
longer than ever
china's preference for male babies means
that between 2020 and 2060
there will be roughly three single men
for every two single
women there's the impact of the
coronavirus pandemic
whose slowing of fertility may simply
hasten the inevitable
or permanently make things worse both
scenarios bad
compounding the problem is the
government's unwillingness to accept
blame or reverse course after 35 years
of the one child policy
there's a desperate need to justify its
costly existence
as of 2015 most families are now allowed
only two children and even that change
in policy has had little effect
finally there's the slow and invisible
nature of the problem
consider the last time you saw a news
headline about declining births
like climate change there will always be
a more urgent crisis that takes
precedence
and because the effects of a demographic
crisis are felt over years
not days those who highlight the problem
will be labeled by many as melodramatic
in other words the slowness of the
problem makes it harder
not easier to mitigate while these facts
have been known for years
only last year did we receive
authoritative confirmation
in china's 2020 census which tallied
14.65 million births
the previous year the lowest level since
1961.
with our fears confirmed now the
question turns to
just how bad will the fallout be
perhaps the closest comparison is the
fate of japan
also once a fast-growing economy hailed
as the next
superpower and also aging with a median
age of 48.6
japan is the second oldest place on
earth today its share of the world's
manufacturing exports has fallen from
12.5
to just 5.2 japan
did not fade into global irrelevance
it's still a great power
but it never fulfilled what once seemed
certain
its rise to rival the us as a superpower
and it never will china's
repayment of its demographic loan will
at a minimum
place a severe strain on its economy
with this strain will likely come a
sobering reassessment of its rise
demography alone cannot predict the
future
and it would be foolish to forecast
specific social or political
implications
but one cannot help but wonder what
drastic things does a nation do
in this limited window of time before
its power wanes
what does a generation of young people
think when they face
far more challenging prospects than did
their parents
and what culture develops in the absence
of any hope for marriage among
34 million men deng xiaoping
may have indeed been right when he
cautioned the asian century
may never arrive and we're just getting
started
china's demographic crisis will soon
seep into its single biggest driver of
growth
the elusive and out-of-control property
market
housing is china's next reckoning a
topic that deserves its own video
next time in part two in the meantime
you may have noticed that the us also
has a tfr of 1.7
well below replacement level does this
mean it's 2
is in for a similar fall find out why or
why not
in the bonus section which replaces this
on nebula
nebula is the streaming site i helped
create to give a home to more
experimental
long-form and special videos like
mustard's beautifully rendered tribute
to the f-117 nighthawk
renee richie's mini documentary looking
back at the introduction of the iphone
and much much more there are no ads
videos are available early and you can
watch entirely exclusive original
content we've partnered with
curiositystream
home to great documentaries on
technology history and science
like this one about the great economist
milton friedman
so that you can get it and nebula for
less than 15
a year sign up with the link in the
description and watch the extended
version of this video
over on nebula